Salut ! comme tous les jours pendant 30 jours cet été, je vous donne une énigme.
Avant de vous donner l'énigme du jour, je vous donne la réponse de l'énigme d'hier, et si vous ne l'avez pas vu, foncez la voir puisque je vais donner la réponse maintenant.
Il vaut mieux que vous voyez l'énigme d'abord.
"De quelle couleur est l'ours ?"
Et bien il est blanc !
C'est un ours blanc.
Parce que notre chasseur est au pôle nord.
Obligatoirement. Au pôle nord ou au pôle sud d'ailleurs.
Alors je sais qu'il n'y a pas d'ours au pôle nord ou au pôle sud, mais on sait que dans les régions froides ce sont des ours blancs.
Comment on sait qu'il est à un des eux pôles ?
Parce qu'il fait 10 km vers le Sud, 10 km vers l'Est et 10 km vers le Nord.
Donc il ne devrait pas retomber sur le même point.
Mais on sait qu'il retombe sur le même point parce que l'ours n'a pas bougé.
Par contre comme on sait qu'il est avec sa boussole,
il fait 10 km vers le Sud,
10 km vers l'Est,
et 10 km vers le Nord.
Et il va faire un triangle.
Puisque le pôle Nord indique le Nord.
Enigme, donc très intéressante.
Mais peut-être pas autant intéressante que l'énigme d'aujourd'hui.
Dans cette septième énigme nous allons imaginer que nous sommes au Moyen-Age, dans un château fictif,
et il y a un roi qui est mourant, et il appelle à son chevet ses deux fils.
Il leur dit: "Mes fils, vous voyez à l'horizon l'église de la ville voisine ?"
Bon, ok, là c'est plutôt la Défense...
"Et bien celui d'entre vous dont le cheval arrivera en dernier à l'église, héritera de toute mon immense fortune."
Les deux fils foncent à l'écurie et ils filent au triple galop dans la ville voisine.
Ils vont le plus rapidement possible à l'église.
Ma question est: Pour quoi ils se dépêchent comme ça ?"
Cherchez bien, vous avez 24H pour trouver. Comme d'habitude je vous donnerai la réponse dans la vidéo de demain.
Profitez du soleil, passez un bel été. N'oubliez pas de vous abonner à la chaine.
Et rendez-vous demain à 17H.
Ciao !